Supply chain security is all the rage in
moving into 2023.
The reason being, there have been some pretty
huge attacks
on well known software that we all use
every single day. Google introduced us to the
Salsa framework for supply chain security and integrity
validation back in 2021.
However,
most people just aren't aware of their coverage
and compatibility
and compliance
with the framework. End to end security doesn't
need to be hard. And today, I'm going
to show you how to get started with
Scribe security.
Scribe security is a framework that you can
use by hooking up a small CICD pipeline
probably with GitHub actions that gives you all
the details that you need to know to
know how compliant with the SASSA framework you
are and how close you may be to
that next level. Scryb security is free for
many organizations.
Free for one seat and up to 100
bills per month. So it's easy for organizations
to get started and understand their compliance across
however many products they have. If you want
to give more people access to your results,
then you will have to adopt one of
their paid tiers.
So go check out the pricing page for
more information. Everything I am doing on the
video today is 100%
under the free plan. And also this video
is sponsored by Scribes Security. They sponsored my
time to take a look at their framework
and show people how to get started. So
without further ado, let's dive in. So let's
start with what I've scanned so far. When
you sign up for Scribe Security, you will
get the demo product which scans a Mongo
Express server.
We can see that the integrity is validated,
and we'll get into that in a moment.
We can see the scan date and time,
number of components,
number of vulnerabilities,
and salsa level and compliance,
as well as the nest score. I've also
forked
a real open source project called Directus,
which is a headless CMS that powers data
frameworks with their Studio UI. I've forked this
instead of using any of my own repositories
just because it is a complete product that
you can use today. A lot of the
code that I have in my repository is
for automation,
platform,
and even clustered,
not something that I would specifically ship to
an end user. So I wasn't getting the
full value from the scans. So for this
demo, let's focus on Directus.
When we click on it, we can see
all of the versions. Every time you push
to the main branch or cut a release
with a tag,
you can have the CICD workflows run against
your software, giving you a new version.
What I like about this, and I'm gonna
show you before we even dive into any
of the result, is that we can publish
these results,
giving access to our customers or our partners
who maybe want assurances
to our security compliance.
When we click on a version,
we get a nice overview
of all of the scans that Scrape Security
has done against our repository
and our build artifacts.
And you can see that Directus
is already Salsa level two compliant.
Hey.
For salsa level three, there are two tasks
out of 12 that need to be completed.
And for this NIST secure software development framework,
we have nine pending tasks or controls that
we need to bring under compliance. On the
right hand side, we have the integrity validation.
This shows us how many open source packages
Directus is consuming under the hood. A whopping
1,071.
Of course, this is a TypeScript project using
NPM and Nodes. Of course, there's gonna be
a lot of dependencies.
We can also see the number of source
files that were scanned. The directors project itself,
almost 2,000
pieces of code. On the bottom, we have
an overview of the vulnerabilities against the container
image that was built for this project.
Right now, we can see that there's one
critical, 16 high,
and then a 80 medium and 49 low.
And again, we'll dive into that in just
a moment. So let's take a look at
our Salsa compliance. You can click on this
compliance tab here, and we'll see the two
controls that have failed that would allow us
to adopt Salsa level three or at least
broadcast and publish that we are Salsa level
three compliant.
Control number one is source history verified.
Assigned commits are not required on this branch,
which is a critical control in Salsa level
three. And also there are no branch protection
rules stopping from force
commits, changing
the history on this branch. That just means
that in theory,
someone with the right level of access could
modify the branch history losing the provenance that
we need that proves the history is what
it claims to be. Now besides the fields,
we can see all of the Salsa controls
that were passed.
Our build was defined as code
using GitHub workflows.
Providence cannot be falsified.
Awesome. The build was executed
by a build service here, GitHub actions.
We have signatures.
The environment is isolated.
The providence is available, which we can click
on and view, which we are viewing. And
all of our code is in version control.
We can then see the nest field controls
below. We can see that we don't have
automatic package scanning for license implications,
the organization's domains, and a secure verified next
to his name and so forth. Now it's
up to you as an organization and as
a team to understand the level of compliance
that you want for your software and you
want to give assurances to your customers.
So really take these controls as a gate.
If you want to get to SANSA level
three, start configuring the GitHub permissions that give
you those assurances.
What I like about some of these controls
is that Scrape Security isn't just taking a
look at my repository and and the artifact.
It's actually taking a look at the GitHub
settings
like these two here. It understands that the
branch protection rules are available, but they're just
not configured the way that we need. So
that's pretty neat. Moving over to vulnerabilities,
we actually get a no understanding
of the packages being consumed by our software.
And we can see the one critical,
which was updated on January 24, which is
for this CVE here,
like so. So it's always great when things
are doing security scanning, link you back to
the source material. Tells you the database that
it came from, the CVSS score, which we
all know is how our mess again is
there to give you more information
and context
to make the sessions yourself. We can see
the affected version of the package
and now we have an understanding that maybe
there is an update and we can go
take a look at that to see if
the CV has been rectified upstream.
If you want to sort by any of
these, you just click the headers much like
we would expect with any UI like so.
Next, we have a software bill of materials
generated
for our application,
and we even can see if the integrity
is validated
across each of these dependencies.
This uses an open source tool that we
covered just recently on Rawkode Academy called GitGap.
If you're curious about that project and how
it works, go click the link in the
description after this video. So we can see
which packages have their integrity validated
when some are not covered. And to be
honest, that is okay. It just means that
they don't have all the same controls in
place on their repository to protect the assurances
that we need with the framework. You see
the package manager used for all of these
and given that this is a TypeScript project,
of course, it's NPM all the way down.
Then we can click on licenses. From here,
we can see all of the licenses,
all of the dependencies to understand
what the coverage is across them all. This
is something that we often don't even think
about as we'd NPM install new packages into
our projects.
Are we governed by any licenses that we
didn't know? This is probably where your legal
team may want to spend some time. If
your application is not open sourced, you may
have to make sure that you are adhering
to the license and the rights given to
you permitted by the upstream open source license
available. Then we have our context. This just
tells us the GET repository and everything else
from the build system that we need to
understand how all this information was generated.
So how did we get all of this
wonderful information
about our repository
and our container image? Let's pop open the
GitHub action. I've given it a name called
scrape security and have asked it to run
on all pushes to the main branch. As
with all GitHub actions, we check out the
source code of the repository.
And then we're using the scrape security
GitHub actions themselves. Here, we're seeing use Scrape
security
action
bomb. We give this an ID so that
we can reference the output of it later,
and we're telling it to scan the current
working directory. You can generate the artifacts without
uploading them to Scrape if you want, but
you can enable the Scrape integration and provide
a client ID and client secret. You can
also provide a product key, which means that
you can name what the product is in
the Scrape UI. Now how do we get
the client ID and the client secret? Well,
from the Scrape page, click on integrations,
where you will see the client ID here
and a sophisticated version of the secret which
you can copy and make available to get
hub actions. Next, we can scan the container
image that is produced by our build system.
Here again, we're using the action bomb action
with the target set to a docker hub
container image. This also works just fine with
g h c r dot I o. Next,
we ask it to upload the two outputs
from our first two scans. Then we do
a salsa statement verification or generation.
We were just asking action bomb to run
one more time. This time, we're asking for
a format
as a salsa statement and then we ask
for the provenance to be uploaded as an
artifact on the build. So in under 55
lines of YAML, we can generate our bill
of materials, scan our container images, upload all
of our artifacts, to scribe,
and get a UI that gives us all
the information that we need to understand our
Salsa compliance, the vulnerabilities within our container images,
and even share them with our customers and
partners. So go check out Scryb. As I
said, for a single seat, 100 builds per
month, you can get started for free. Enjoy.